the NRA of course the National Rifle
Association is the largest gun lobby in
the United States they have now named
former convicted felon and illegal
firearms salesperson Oliver North as
their president and you might be saying
David what do you mean former convicted
felon you're either someone who is a
convicted felon or you're not and what I
mean is that Oliver North was convicted
in the iran-contra affair in the late
80s and those convictions were
eventually reversed and charges were
dismissed so while he was at one point a
convicted felon he is no longer but just
because the legal system can reverse the
conviction doesn't mean that it can
reverse Oliver North being a horrible
person and one of the things North did
was to sell guns illegally do you
understand the sick irony of this the
guy who is going to run the biggest gun
rights group and gun lobby previously
sold guns illegally to Iran and to
terrorists his involvement in the
iran-contra affair was participating in
the sale of weapons to Iran with money
passing through shell organizations and
then his later political life has also
just been horrible and the NRA has named
him the president replacing Peter
Brownell who decided not to run for a
second term we heard from Wayne LaPierre
he's the executive vice president of the
NRA he says that the selection of Oliver
North as their president is the most
exciting news for NRA members since
Charlton Heston was president of the NRA
so there's been a while since they've
been this excited aside from being a
convicted felon a former convicted felon
involved in illegal gun sales North also
just represents the idea of government
outside of our Constitution because when
he was involved in his illegal gun sales
he was involved in what was a government
plot that included money laundering
supplying arms to hostile nations and in
too many ways it's similar to what we're
seeing under the Trump administration
actually and I even know a few Second
Amendment folks here in Massachusetts
not NRA folks right like they're not
extreme Second Amendment people they
often are not even NRA members they
think that this is terrible they think
that this is terrible not only for the
NRA
itself but for legal and and moderate
gun owners everywhere to have someone
like Oliver North with the corruption
and criminality that he has in his
background and it's not just general
wrongdoing its wrongdoing specifically
when it comes to weapons to have this
guy leading the NRA is angering even
moderate Second Amendment people and in
a way it's not even that shocking right
the fact that in a time where Trump said
he was going to drain the swamp and it's
been just filling of the swamp in a time
when everything is the opposite
everything that Hillary Clinton and
Barack Obama and Democrats have been
accused of doing by Trump through his
campaign and by Republicans everything
they've accused they are doing
themselves why not bring in a guy who
has a problem with guns and and the law
to actually run the National Rifle
Association it's insanity and it's
insanity and how it's not even really
that shocking because there were like
five bigger scandals just in the last 24
hours